so uh let's start with Brandon um what
are where are you familiar with
Hellraiser before you got this role yeah
I probably watched the original
Hellraiser when I was about nine years
old and uh of course insanely confused
and Disturbed
um but all in all the Full Circle
journey to being a part of the this sort
of reintroduction to it in the Modern
Age
um there's a lot more clarity and a lot
more like um respect for what Clive
Barker did and and the visions that have
come through through the last 10 movies
and now with David bruckner's version
and Odessa what about you
raise her before you got this role yeah
I was always familiar with it it wasn't
something that I watched when I was
younger just because uh my
units never showed me but
um I probably watched it like around
like 14 or 15 for the first time and um
it's like the effects are
just like you don't see that in
a lot of
like OG horror movies like that so
yeah I love Hellraiser that's that's
when I probably first saw it that's what
I love about ours is we did all pretty
practical just like the original was the
attempt to create the
um the physical effects to an Ode to the
original I think I think so for sure
yeah I think David definitely wanted it
to be like
yeah yeah just paying it paying it
forward to the original like that like
it was all practical just the same way
as as you know in the first Hellraiser
movie when Frank is is um
reforming in real life it was just him
melting and we and then they reversed
the picture so we did the same thing
with a lot of like blood being uh sucked
into the box that was actually uh
letting blood pour out of the box and
then reversing the image as well so I
thought yeah cool
um did you get to play with the lament
configuration boxes
oh yeah yeah the boxes were all
practical as well
with that
was that like kind of crazy especially
for you Brandon since you saw it when
you were such a little kid was that like
kind of awe-inspiring yeah it was pretty
interesting especially because I think
this movie like the box is such a like
an important
um thing and character that we that we
actually track
um I feel like this movie we understand
the Box more than we ever have in the
Hellraiser landscape
um and and David was incredibly specific
with how the box would work with
understanding each eats each um
change
configuration that's the better word
yeah thank you
um so it was it was pretty pretty cool
and what about you Odessa did you get to
play with the boxes at all I played with
like um every configuration and which
was also like Brandon said it was also
practical so every time I'm
you I would turn it and then you'd have
to take the you know when the knife
comes out then you'd put the knife in
and then and then cut back to it and we
do like like switches like switch off
the boxes and they're also like falling
apart in your hands as you're like
playing with them you have to like
pretend that it's like really like hard
to move sometimes but it was really fun
to play with them and like amazing that
they they
really went into detail on these boxes I
I think this one this movie you can you
can see that more than
um others before not discrediting them
just saying that like I think that
people are really gonna love that you
could see the details of it even more
and it focuses on like what the puzzle
box can do
um right as well as the center bites
right I was gonna ask um can you talk
about working with the cenobites were
they um in real life were they as
fearsome as they appeared on screen I
mean not personality I'm sure the actors
were lovely but I mean Jason I just
wanted to hug him the whole time I felt
bad that he was in that
he was like like uh screwed in to his
suit
like it took a full five minutes every
time he wanted to get out and take a
breather but
it was definitely
freaked out by some of them but for most
of it was just like
it was fun to do it all together yeah I
think it all like made the fantasy that
much more like interesting and fun to
play and like these they they looked
just like they look in the movie on set
you know which was on one hand like very
funny to like just you know get to like
your set which I think the first time I
met Jamie was like a playground and she
was like in the holding room with with a
cup of coffee as the Priestess and um it
was like what the hell am I looking at
um but also once the camera started
rolling it was just this understanding
of like this is what the audience is
gonna get and that's
so cool well thank you guys so much I
really appreciate it and it was a really
fun movie so thanks so much